here's your receipt
let me just bag these up and you'll be
good to go Thanks whoo Miller Lite punch
top cans good choice you were using one
of these before
and the flow watch how smooth it is
smooth not smooth smooth not smooth not
smooth not smooth smooth look cool right
what are you doing I'm bagging your
groceries you pouring them out I'm not
pouring them out I'm pouring them in
your bag so when you get home it's
quicker and easier yeah it's a
full-service grocery store and I'm your
full-service grocer I just want to make
your experience as pleasant as possible
sir yeah like this fruit on the bottom
yogurt we premix it for you don't
let's get that fruit on top mmm please
don't
there you go mmm true can't hide no more
awesome okay you know what I don't want
the full service so stop don't worry
about it it's my pleasure
like these bananas have you ever gotten
home and had some bananas and you're
like how how how do I get in there no
well not today one two three you got a
bag of loose bananas peel like Charles
Chaplin slip on those I said I don't
want the full service I'm saving you
time and energy like how many times have
you been home and you're like I want
some cereal but I don't have the will to
open both a box and a bag never I'm here
to make sure that never happens again
come on no prize
you picked a grownup cereal okay okay
okay we stop no more full-service don't
worry it's free of charge
oh look grapes don't touch my great
delicious but hard to digest
let me pre smush him for you oh stop it
clean up on aisle behind the aisles
clean up on the aisle behind we don't
have a code for that I want to talk to a
manager you know it's weird I am the man
Oh God
will you stop you know what I'm not the
manager
well the Wilson manager I want Oh
pickles you know I want to become the
manager hmm and this is one of the ways
I'm trying to become the manager by
going the extra mile can you help a lady
hmm you're a strong one now let's get
these chunks out of your delicious
pickle juice no no no no no I wanted
those you want these I did that's weird
you want the juice no but it's it's
included all right just give me a refund
right now oh I'm sorry I can't take a
refund on open merchandise